[Music]
homie look what I become
okay so it's haunting today with uh
sauce Vinnie uh Tom Ellsworth and uh
Malik AKA in the house we got a lot of
stories to cover with you Adam took me
to a wonderful dinner last night I'll
tell you about it anytime just an
incredible dinner Adam took us to at
this point folks I do have a one a
warning to all of you and a suggestion
if you guys want to live a uh peaceful
life one of the things that's starting
to happen to a lot of people I suggest
you start thinking about this as well
whatever you do just go look around your
house to see if you have any classified
documents because
I just have some classes
looking at one of these look at what no
I'm dead serious and look Hunter was
here oh
even even here by the way pants you know
you know what it is I bet there's people
in politics that are pissed off they're
like dude can you just put something in
my because I want to get some publicity
yeah put something here for me to say
I'm turning in my cloud documents more
is coming out God you know
documentary yeah Mike Pence everything's
really solid Christian vice president
had some classified documents so he
joined the camp we'll talk about that
Goldman Sachs says four cities will
suffer a 2008 crash type in home values
if you are from those four cities don't
listen to this podcast if you want to
know stick around we will share it with
you biggest pay raises went to Black
workers young people and low-wage
earners according to Wall Street Journal
interesting we'll talk about that poll
64 say Biden handle classified files
inappropriately apparently Trump is back
on Facebook and Instagram and obviously
Twitter was a couple months ago but now
it's Facebook and Instagram uh yesterday
project Veritas sat down and got a
chance to sit down with one of their
directors that talked about what they
want to do with the vaccines and the guy
opened up and he says you can't tell
this to anybody and and someone said the
way they got the date with this guy was
through Grindr because he really
interesting so I'm telling you really
really interesting
that that was one of the ways that they
got the guy to open up because
apparently he felt comfortable Google's
going through a mess right now uh uh uh
Taylor Swift maybe we'll cover that
obviously the antifa if we have time
we'll cover that
um Amazon warns employees not to share
confidential information with chat gbt
after seeing cases where it's answers
closely matches existing materials from
inside the company Jeff Bezos may sell
Washington Post to buy commanders as if
he needs to sell it to buy commanders
yeah Pfizer seal Albert borea rough week
for this guy seriously refuses to reply
impromptu questions put forth by Rebel
news maybe we'll talk about it
scientists are working
on a coveted vaccine you can drink by
the way this is a CNET story this is not
like a joke yeah scientists are working
on a covet vaccine you can drink
especially those of you that love
vaccines this is great news for some
that want more of it and then you know
something's going on with Andrew Tate
you know Pleasant prison plea he talks
about cockroaches lice and bed bugs are
my only friends I don't know if you got
someone they got out yesterday ask the
cops if they have anything to show Tate
said Tristan said and an lgbtq families
Mall leaving Florida in Wake of new
culture laws that's a Herald Tribune
story maybe we'll get into some of the
stories anyways let me first give a
quick shout out to our sponsors
Masterworks I'm really excited about
this company we chose to team up but if
you want to show this year here's how
art is done over the years a lot of
people ask me questions and they'll say
Pat how could you buy baseball cards and
I'll say how could you not yeah I mean
the only reason you should not if you
don't know how this works but art and
cards are very similar when you look at
alternative Investments today
you will see the goldness of the world
the black rocks of the world the Morgan
stanleys of the world a lot of them are
starting to look at alternative funds
meaning art that you can buy
what Masterworks did uh uh love their
model that I believe they have 600 000
users right now uh 600 million dollars
of assets under management uh last year
was a record-breaking year in arts being
sold ever in the history of America 18
billion dollars folks of art was sold
last year when you look at the inflation
last time it was this high was 1977
through 1982 the art 100 index
appreciated 130 during that time from
then to now and inflation 80 percent so
this is something for you to consider
Contemporary Art annual average right
now is appreciation is 13.8 percent if
you want to learn more about it these
are these art pieces that they have it
could be Banksy it could be Picasso
You're simply buying a share in the art
that they're selling so if you can't
afford to buy three million dollar piece
of the art maybe you own one share to 3
million just the same way you buy apple
or Amazon stock you buy a stock into the
art pieces they buy very straight up
model it's qualified with the SEC I said
just you look into this for yourself
before you make any investment so if you
want to learn more let's put the link
below it is not open to everybody but
they're allowing folks to come in if you
are a valuetainer there's a link
specifically through vitamin that you
can go in check them out and if you feel
comfortable consider investing with
Masterworks having said that let's get
ready yes I'm funny you say that and
it's totally random I bought I bought a
Biden when the hunter Biden's paintings
well good for I don't know if they're
going to have that kind of a painting
but this is actually real stuff that
they're doing and people are truly like
investing into art today Tom what was
the story you told me about the one art
piece you bought and then you sold it
and what's the value today it's a Warhol
I believe yeah it's a war Hall and uh by
the way uh Happy Birthday Buzz Aldrin
about a week ago second man to walk on
the moon it's like 92 years old I also
got married that was a great set they
had go ahead he was he was the astronaut
that was Steve
[Laughter]
but you remember Buzz Aldrin and Beverly
Hills punched the guy who said I saw
that yeah
that's why the original the original
logo for MTV was actually Andy Warhol
print first man on moon remember that
okay yeah and that was Buzz Aldrin
photograph taken by Neil Armstrong Rob
give that pin so I bought I bought the
it's called moonwalk and there were
um uh yep there it is of course MTV he
made two of them one was in yellow one
was in pink I I owned the yellow one
bought it for 10 sold it for 17. million
dollars thousand dollars and by the way
that was back in 2000 2002 and then this
thing had an auction where an identical
pair that were the same number because
there was only about 100 of each made
along with artists groups and these
things went for 400 grand for a pair how
long ago was this six years ago this was
Christie's last year okay I owned it in
2000 2002. so that's the part about our
time you know at your point you're so
skeptical and then you buy you sit on it
and all of a sudden it goes from 10
grand to four when did you buy for 10
grand 2 000 and then I sold it in 2012
years it went from 10 grand to 400 Grand
but look what I was thinking I bought it
for 10 sold it for 17. I'm thinking 75
yeah but it was a similar position
happened to me with a cobra original
yeah Warhol that was one of the
originals wow by the way shout out to
Buzz Aldrin
how much younger is as hotter as his
wife listen she probably sits there and
says that this guy can't land on the
moon I wonder what he lands with me so
I'm curious to know where this is I'm a
rock your world girl but you land on my
moon you know you said something earlier
it was you know we all familiar with the
S P 500 and the national business 100
yeah that's a that's an index what is
that it's a fund it's a fun just like
you know there's a gold fund there's a
you know currency fund there's even
crypto funds nowadays there is an art
fund this is a real thing by the way so
it's not like just uh you know when
whenever you see billionaires going into
art and kind of seeing what you ought to
just pay attention to it you ought to
just say let me see why they're doing it
now if you're not a billionaire you
don't have that kind of money but maybe
you got five thousand ten thousand
hundred thousand and you're thinking
about buying a piece of a bank seat or a
Picasso this is one way to get it
anyways let's get into stories let's get
into stories let's get into stories
uh let's see let's go with Goldman Sachs
that's the story I want to go into first
because it's economy so let's look at
this
uh Goldman Sachs has four cities will
suffer a 2008 crash in home values the
stories from a couple days ago they
predict that home values will worsen
then uh through 2023
due to skyrocketing interest rates and
declining housing prices The Firm
predict that San Jose it's a lot of
Sands San Diego Austin and Phoenix will
see the most drastic decreases of over
25 percent similar to 2008 just in 2023.
Como sax expects interest rates to
remain at elevated levels longer than
currently priced in which the 10-year
treasury yields pre-kink in 2023 and
raising their forecast for the 30-year
fixed mortgage to six and a half percent
by the end of 2023 the bank states that
these cities will suffer the lowest
prices this year because they become too
detached from fundamentals during the
covid-19 pandemic housing boom Tom what
are your thoughts on this uh Pat this is
what we've been saying isn't it and this
is just the first set now Goldman Sachs
as said here's the first set and these
are the ones that are going to fall the
farthest so they're easiest to predict
now there's other places in the country
that are stable like right now Florida's
prices are stable kind of down four and
a half percent what I was reading and
it's because there's still enough demand
in Florida to keep them there and
there's not supply to push it down but
the transactions aren't happening so
this is just the beginning of what we've
been talking about for nine months the
interest rates the overpriced market and
now here it comes it's coming back and
the question is the reason you have a
crash Why do you have a crash because
the price will fall until someone says
I'll buy it
that's how the auction that's how an
inverted auction crash works is the
prices keep dropping until somebody says
you know I'll buy it just like the price
of art will keep going up at an auction
at Christie's until somebody says I'm
out that guy can have the painting it's
the exact same thing just in Reverse we
saw this coming we've been talking about
it for a while Rob can you pull this up
I'm about to send this to Adam you can
give some thoughts until he brings it up
go ahead yeah well I actually kind of
took the look at why these four cities
we've all seen what's happening in South
Florida especially in Florida uh you
know what goes boom must go bust uh
except for I think in South Florida and
and where I'm kind of going with this is
east coast versus West Coast everyone on
the East Coast anyone in the Northeast
and if you're New York Boston Jersey we
everyone is coming down to South Florida
they call Miami the sixth Borough
because they're not going to Atlanta
they're not going to South Carolina
they're not even going to North Carolina
some people are but everyone on the East
Coast that says screw it we're going
south to Florida all right cool so we
can put that aside everyone on the west
coast there's so many different options
out there if you're in California you
can go North to Oregon you go north of
Seattle you go a little bit further east
now you're in uh Vegas you go south
you're in Texas like there's so many
different options out there but each of
these four cities I was kind of going
through this with my buddy Joe who's
here today shout out to Joe and each of
these cities have actually a very
nuanced approach so if you're looking at
San Jose San Jose is what 20 minutes
outside of San Francisco hello tech jobs
we're seeing what's happening in the
tech space Microsoft Google you know the
list goes on and on about how many uh
people are getting cut from their jobs
10 000 jobs being cut okay so that's
Tech the Austin same thing with tech
right isn't Austin a tech bubble as well
yeah so and it's also what do they say
keep awesome very good point you're
making yeah yeah and yeah then they call
Austin Texas so hilarious and then
obviously everything that's going on in
California shout out to Gavin Newsom for
the being the U-Haul employee of the
year for the two years running shout out
to you everybody's amazing with him MPP
California politics at the cost of
living it's crazy San Diego weird City
beautiful city expensive though why are
you moving to San Diego what's the
industry in San Diego last but not least
this is something that could raise a
different conversation Phoenix
how much of that is immigration how much
of that is immigration basically people
saying yeah I don't like what's going on
here and in Phoenix so each of these
cities are very weird but uh back to
your point Tom you know the the
underlying tone here is interest rates
inflation cost of living for sure but
then there's a multitude
Stay classy when you talk about San
Diego
can we go a whale's vagina can we go to
this story here so if you can show this
that's what he said by the way yesterday
we talked about what we believe what's
done about that story with her maybe
anyway so this is Bloomberg so we want
to show both sides of the story
Bloomberg shows and uh housing demand
climbs as the U.S market starts to show
signs of Life great so for those that
are on real estate this is a plug for
you go and zoom in a little bit so I can
read exactly what it's saying in the
description if you can't do it okay
there you go perfect housing demand is
starting to show signs of recovery and
what pending sales of U.S home prices uh
home Rising for the first time in more
than a year according to a new data from
Red fin pending sales climb 2.9 of
December on a seasonally adjusted basis
this is the first month over month
increase since October of 2021 Redfin
says on Wednesday uh other measures of
demand including data on brokerage
customers requesting home tours and
people contacting the company's agents
are up from November read more at the
link in the bio so go to the Bottom now
and let's see what people say I want to
read the comments now if you can zoom in
a little bit so you can it says first
one did a realtor write this number two
don't do it next one I was literally
going over data last night that shows
the opposite next one this is completely
false on all sorts of data Austin Texas
is not having any issues like Bloomberg
post every week you'll be broke believe
in everything this page posts LOL LOL so
contradict I mean by the way it's like
99 of the comments are saying you are
full of [__] is what they're saying to
Bloomberg right so listen here's what
we're gonna know what we're gonna know
for sure is by the end of the year my my
the way I measure real estate is the
following way
ask the average real estate agent the
other day I was on the play Travis and
buck uh Buck show which is great they're
great at what they do and we're talking
about the economy and I said you know if
you want to measure how good real estate
is doing ask a realtor and ask him how
do you think 2023 is going to do you
know what their answer is it's great no
no no this is their answer they'll say
well I think 2023 is going to be a flat
year it's what's going to happen and
then I think 24 25 is going to be a
great year if a realtor
whose very motivational wakes up every
morning listening to motivational videos
tells you it's going to be a flat year
it's going to be a down year okay
because that's just how these things
work if they tell you it's going to be
freaking great sick it's probably going
to be okay so flat ear means just you
know if you're gonna sell and you're
gonna if you're gonna live in your house
for more than five years you have
nothing to worry about if you're going
to live in more than 10 years you're
already in it but if you're debating
leaving six months 12 months 18 months
don't be too greedy right now you may
want to consider selling your house and
if you're about to buy a place if you're
about to buy a place we're going to buy
this building down the street for uh
they were in it for 54 million you know
which one I'm talking about 150 000
square foot building we go and we look
at it the guy says they'll take 32
million right now I said I'm not doing
32. he says don't offer anything less
than 28 it's offensive I made an offer
of 26. by the way they said they walked
that same building we made an off run
six seven eight months ago they were in
the house yes in the building yesterday
upstairs when you came in oh [__] that
was that the good first of all you know
what Vinnie does listening Vinnie out of
everything I'm having a serious business
meeting this guy's working on his skin
no joke did you hear what he did
okay so yes he
comes in with a briefcase saying Pat
where do you want me to leave the supply
they just dropped off he opens it up
it's a bat it's a bag with sugar in it
that looks like cocaine
did you understand what I just said like
he showed me the second floor is Serious
Business Vinnie first floor he told me
it wasn't serious people are you kidding
me that guy that guy has a half a
billion dollars of real estate you know
what somebody in here was like no Vinnie
go mess with pennies long story short I
talked to the guy so now the same
property they wanted 50 that went from
54 to 32 you know what they're willing
to sell right now 20 million dollars so
I made a 50 million dollar offer but
here's the date it took the 26. they
should have taken 26 I would have bought
it pat did me come than me showing up
with by the way when I tell you
beautiful building I mean beautiful Tom
is it a beautiful building it's a
beautiful office Crystal Clear building
everything Immaculate but so we're gonna
find out what's gonna happen on real
estate I'm giving you commercial real
estate I'm not telling you residential
I'm giving you strictly commercial but
we're gonna see what's gonna happen real
estate next 12 months the reality is
someone's going to be right A lot of
people
did my fake cocaine story like me coming
in mind you it wasn't for you I came in
and I said to HR I go guys I'm sorry to
interrupt I go HR a delivery from some
Bolivian guy and Rob HR is like
get on Pat your panelists Pat was
laughing they told me down here it
wasn't like really serious I never told
you they yeah check it with somebody
before you walk into a business yeah
anyways can I ask you a question just
whether it's real estate or investment
something that you always say repeatedly
is listen if you're going to be living
there five years or longer ten years or
longer it's fine it's fine it's fine
right and something that I say there's a
difference between saving and investing
saving a short term whether it's 12 24
36 months anything less than that save
save save save save keep it short term
five years or longer I would put in the
investment category this goes the same
for housing how do you determine where
to stack your cash saving wise versus
investing is there a rule of thumb is
there a time frame is there a horizon
how do you process that whether it's
real estate whether it's art whether
it's cash whether it's Investments how
do you how do you the guy sitting next
processities like have you gone into
nfts yet I said no did you ever get into
nfts I said no wait so you're a YouTuber
and you didn't get into I said first of
all I'm not a YouTuber I'm a business
guy I run companies but no I never got
into nfds you know how much money people
made in nfts I'm clearly aware of the
people who made the money and I know the
thousands who lost a lot of money what's
going to happen long term I don't know
if they deliver on their utilities Etc
it's a 97 nfts are a wasted time anyways
then he talks about crypto how about
Bitcoin how about this how about that
for me My Philosophy is simple what I
know a lot about I comfortably invest in
I will gladly deploy five 10 million
autos on baseball cards and not even
Flinch because I know what I'm buying I
know the product I'm buying you've seen
me do it over the years so it's not like
it's a you know so I'll deploy that no
problem Aries I'm not an expert guy
asked me a question yesterday saying so
what what should I do to increase my
rental income in the amount of
properties I buy what do you do I said
I'm just the wrong Zoom because I'm not
that guy I don't know my specialty is in
real estate my specialty isn't dealing
with renters I don't want that drama I
don't want my property manager to call
me about that drama I like to operate
and build companies is what I like when
I was getting started at 21 22 years old
and I had no clue what I was doing
I open up a mutual fund account and I
started with 100 bucks a month okay and
I open up a vul and I put 100 a month
into it that's when I was broke and that
money would just go on and gradually I
would raise it from 100 to 200 to 200 to
300 300 to 400 500 000 a month and then
one day you wake up you're like wait I
got 360 000 in this account that's kind
of cool how did this happen to me yeah
I'd always kiss and then you're like
okay what can I do with this and then
you get a little bit more and more and
more sophisticated because people are
dealing with additional things as well
today when you're looking at your money
it has to do with your age your risk
tolerance at 64 should not be the risk
tolerance of a 42 year old and shouldn't
be the risk tolerance of a 22 year old
those things vary ages vary the other
part about when it comes down to this is
time Horizon you got short-term midterm
long term what portion of your money do
you need short term if your daughter is
getting married in two years and you
need to be paying for that wedding and
it's going to be a couple hundred
thousand dollars or a hundred thousand
dollars you need to set that money aside
because that time is coming if kids are
about to go to college and then don't
have the GPA to get scholarship you need
that money to be set aside to be paired
that's short term midterm again depends
how old your kids are depends if you're
married depends any of that stuff and
then long term long term then the last
thing is with your money that you have
you sit there and you say which which
portion of my money am I comfortable
losing a hundred percent of
that shouldn't be a big percentage you
could say only five percent fine so if
you're five percent is a hundred
thousand dollars fifty thousand dollars
twenty thousand dollars a million
dollars
you can you can afford putting in Risky
Investments that you may lose all of it
but you cannot lose sleep so if you're
the kind of a person that will lose
sleep if you lose that kind of money
don't do it because it's going to mess
with you only do it if you know your
temperament investing is very different
for different people it's different for
you than my temperament than his
temperament and his temperament people
come to me and they say why are you
always sitting on so much cash and why
are you not deploying do you know how
much money that's costing you I said
that's my temperament because I'm able
to invest that money right now where the
conversation we had yesterday in the
office time was it upstairs or I don't
know yeah it was upstairs when we're
having a conversation one conversation
went from me agreeing to want to put
seven million dollars into one project
that will probably end up being a 12
million dollar project another one I'm
deploying 19 million dollars into the
project of my own money but these are
things I am very very comfortable doing
because of my temperament don't let
somebody's aggressive big Vision big
thinking temperament working 60 80 hours
a week influence you on what you should
do what you your temper with your money
when yours is more chilling out so it's
it's not a one you know shoe fits you
know one size it's not you got to kind
of figure out what's for you okay let's
transition to the next topic because we
got quite a few of them I just want to
give a quick response number one you
know things are doing well in your life
when you use the word deploy I'm
deploying this investment I'm deploying
this or you were in the military lived
in the Middle East and those words we're
deploying a several times we're
deploying troops but uh we're just just
to your credit we were talking last
night with my good buddy Chris and he's
talking about the restaurant industry
and this and that I have all these
franchises and you said you could have
gone any response he gave you a whole
like kind of dissertation you go okay
that's not me it's just not me yeah I
could put I could deploy five million
dollars for whatever and you're just
like it's not me the hardest thing to do
when somebody's pitching you pitching
you pitching you're gonna be like I'm
good I'm good no it's not for me it's so
easy to be like oh tell me more it's
just sexy I don't know can I make money
it's very hard to be like no it's just
not my Lane yeah stay in your lane by
the way and that leads me into this next
story I'm gonna go to page number nine
story okay which the scientists are
working on covid vaccine you can drink
finally you can okay finally so let me
read this to you a new type of X this is
a CNET story a new type of accent called
mucosal vaccines which can take uh can
be taken as they Swish and swallow oral
vaccine or nasal vaccine is being
developed and could be available within
a couple years the q-y-n-d-r as if we
need another acronym to remember oral
vaccine developed by the U.S specialty
formulations has completed its phase one
clinical trial and is waiting on funding
to proceed to more advanced trials the
vaccine is designed to survive the
digestive system and induce the
appropriate response to clinical trial
results from New Zealand are promising
and offer hope that the vaccine will be
available a viable option for protection
against the current covid-19 variants
however in order to get the vaccine to
be Advanced to additional clinical
trials funding from investors is needed
okay so if you guys wanting to invest
this the story from CNET you can go look
into it when when you hear something
like this what do you think about you
know for for me if this is a business
model you know like a CBD okay or or THC
or you say so now what are we doing
let's let's talk about it from Strictly
the business model standpoint on what
Pfizer is doing what these guys are
doing
I don't smoke weed I probably should but
I don't smoke weed okay it'd be fun I
don't drink coffee thank God I don't
yeah you don't want me to drink coffee I
shouldn't drink Red Bull monster what
else is there any of that stuff don't
don't get it close to me okay one time
we tested my urine and it they said this
is the closest thing to Red Bull that's
what they say that's a joke you don't
need more but I don't need any of it
right but you know wheat is a different
story okay so anyways so this guy's like
well you know we're selling wheat oil
now coal hey this guy says you're having
lower back pains try the CBD oil to put
on your lower back like does that mean
my back is getting high what does it
mean your spine hey if if you're if you
try these gummy bears okay or try these
cookies or try this right anyways what's
the point
if it's legal and you're finding
creative ways for people to be able to
buy that guess what credit goes to to
the team the seller that is getting
creative so if vaccine is one method is
what shot and they wanting to go on this
side from the standpoint of innovation
on how to get it into the system fine
you can tell them good for the team that
thought about this now the other thing
you have to pose and ask the question is
level of trust how comfortable people
are about it is it something where the
timing is good right now to announce it
is it becoming to the point where
everybody is in the camp of yes I'll
take it I don't know what are your
thoughts what are your thoughts I think
I think the fact and from what we saw
that they said I don't think I've ever
said this please raise Vinnie's audio by
about five percent are you serious
that's the first person did you guys
hear that he lowered it by 10 when you
were yelling about yourself but uh but
Pat think about it as a business
standpoint what what they did with fauci
and everybody in the government they
scared the [__] out of everybody yeah so
and you we all know these type of people
that like another booster give it to me
give it to me give it to me I give them
props because now they they have their
their loyal brainwashed customers now
just another delivery system like you
said if they say there's a vaccine
shampoo I guarantee you people will just
the more the better and then and as
we're finding out Pat the the the the
the science hasn't been tested long
enough to find out if it's gonna affect
you which I think we're seeing that
people are dropping left and right they
don't give a [__] just give them more
give them more I give them props as the
seller but as the people people need to
still wake the house Tom what are you
thinking uh well there's two things I
see here I see a startup business in
biotech that's talking about clinical
trials Advanced trials in other words
not operation warp speed doing something
over the course of time that that
medications and vaccines have been
tested in history not this BS
acceleration that we had along with
amnesty for the vaccine makers I see
that on one side the other side I see a
glaring hole in this business model if I
was an investor I'm sitting there I
would say so you think there's going to
be a long-term market for covid vaccines
so you think covet is here to stay and
all the mutations are here to stay you'd
think there's a long-term market and I
would be sitting there thinking there
saying
wow you know if there's really a
long-term market for this then unlike
swine flu went bird flu one remember
hhv whatever it was bird flu it kind of
came and went because
there was there was
um you know it ran the cycle it ran the
human cycle and what have we heard about
swine bird flu southeast Asia over the
last eight years yeah gone yep it's not
gone but we don't hear about it anymore
because it is not affecting the mass of
society so I look at this and I say so
there's really going to be a long-term
Market on covid you know are we the Lab
Rats somebody out there mutating this
and so that they can sell product or
finding out that they are though you
know last night we're sitting at this
wonderful event with Adam and um so
sitting across this guy who was a
follower of the podcast great guy 37
years old successful guy solid guy good
looking guy
and he says you know Patrick 99 of what
you say I sit down I say yep I agree
yeah he's probably listening yep I agree
yep I agree but there's the one part
where you're not for dmts and not for
psychedelics and all this stuff I'm like
dude we gotta get Patrick on
psychedelics I remember I've never been
a drug guy Never Smoke Weed never did
this never did that 34 years old I went
through a bad breakup first time I did
you know psychedelics it was
life-changing for me I said that's
awesome man very happy for you so then
the guy to my left is like your
personality I know you probably would
never do psychedelics but maybe you
would it's like okay here we go so now
I'm invited to a party where everybody
wants to wants to get me to do
psychedelics okay great fantastic
another a great party that everybody
wants me to do something so then this
girl shows up hi hi
oh two eyes so look you know we're
trying to get Patrick to do psychedelics
so why don't you try psychedelics yeah
she says
uh do you uh follow science
I said define that but no no she
literally says she says do you follow
signs yeah I said can you define that
because it's been a little bit confusing
it's just no science I said well if I
have to trust the science that means I
have to take vaccine and no I don't
trust that science but what do you mean
by science she says well let me ask you
a different question then do you trust
the FDA no
she says um uh uh what do you believe in
I said so what do you believe in she
says no I'm asking a new question I said
I want to know what you believe in well
I believe uh in spirits collagen I
believe in uh you know certain what did
she say she said some stuff like this
like you know and that energy if I can't
have my energy I can give it to you I
said I agree with that and I'm saying
that so I agree with that she says she
says so now I'm going to ask the
question what do you believe in I said
uh I believe in God I believe in good
relationships I believe in never
compromising your values and principles
that fully believe in your convictions
don't convince everybody to buy into
your vision not everybody's going to
understand your vision and then she says
well you know as she says so you would
never you would probably never do and
she says what if I bring you an expert
that gives you all the data and all the
Articles all of it that proves that
psychedelics are good for you I said I'd
love to have him debate somebody who's a
doctor and a scientist who has articles
that that scientist has not shown yeah
that opposes why psychedelics maybe
aren't good for you and I would listen
to that debate and I would make up my
mind at the end she said you just sound
close-minded oh God and then Adam asked
a question and says so tell me about you
you know Adam's trying to be his sweet
self so he says so tell me about
yourself
so are you married do you have kids or I
don't know what you asked are you
married she says you would never ask a
man that question and then Adam says I
actually would ask it all the time said
why are you so defensive yeah so she's
now turning red oh God so I'm talking to
my boy here I'm having a really good
time with this guy because we're talking
about trying to figure people's
personalities based on when they're born
psychedelic guy or this guy's a chill
guy he's a guy with Deepak
really enjoying him he's he's half
Persian half uh Venezuelan half all this
stuff literally yeah great conversation
and I'm getting up I'm like okay Adam
I'm gonna take off man I'm gonna go home
she says oh I'm so sorry did I say I
said no yes listen my life is too great
for you to upset me thank you so much it
was great talking to you I'm gonna take
off and the entire time was like trying
to now redeem herself from this high
quality here's the point she seemed like
a sweetheart
she's just been fed because she's from
what was your Maryland Venture Capital
she traveled six months all this other
stuff right in that world you trust
science
in the world and the life I've lived you
trust debate you trust people debating
because if you've lived my life that's
what I trust I trust two experts who are
a hundred percent convinced they're
right let them hash it up and one of the
things I said last time I don't know if
you remember this I said I said uh you
know what we've learned the last two and
a half years she said what I said
experts using data have forced all of us
to believe in what they're believing in
and they've divided the world so I don't
trust experts that use certain data they
want to choose to validate their
arguments I kind of want to see both
sides I like debate and then there was
done with discussion we moved on and was
she good looking was she at least good
looking she's doing okay she was all
right well I'll I'll tell one story and
then I'll Circle back to what you were
saying back to the the drugs and the
sampling and all that so there's this
it's sort of have you had a nice dinner
it's like a very exclusive type of
situation you're not trying to offend
people but there's this like
contentiousness and I don't know how it
got directed at Pat what do you believe
and know what do you believe and I'll
tell you how I say you know what I
believe and let me tell you what I
believe it she goes okay go ahead I go I
believe
that the children
are the future and by the way I say the
next line I'm like you gotta teach them
well let them leave and let them lead
the way she doesn't she's like okay we
keep going I'm like because what you
have to do oh I love you guys I have to
show them all the beauty so they possess
inside give them a sense of prize to
make it easier right
but
pitching Pat and I said this I said look
if the options are
psychedelics and marijuana as an example
versus pills and alcohol for people who
are suffering with depression uh what do
they get in the military after anxiety
I'm 100 advocate of that but I guess
that there's certain people that just
don't need anything and then Pat said
something very amazing he said I believe
this is not a song He's I believe that
if a lion could speak you would not
understand what they were saying I mean
I'll let you kind of explain this but
there's some people that don't need any
extra stuff in their system they just
got it they wake up like from his I need
some coffee in my life yeah every once
in a while I need a drink I only smoke a
drink whatever I need a little something
yeah Pat needs none of that if a lion
can speak I don't understand them
explain what you were saying with that
all I said is I think the right person
in your life is just as effective if not
10 times more effective than any
psychedelic yeah because the right
person in your life is going to get you
to question things and get clear in your
life and confidence and realize it's not
that big of a deal or maybe it is part
of it is your responsibility but we're
not perfect we got to move on this is a
chance for you to redeem yourself have
some respect for yourself the other
person let's see what we can do
the right person can get you to really
you're laughing it looks like you got a
joke it's not a joke but and I want to
know what the chat things or what the
chat thinks about this why don't what if
they would like this bat we have a
shaman come in here for one podcast they
get us all in Ayahuasca I'm talking
about time and just what kind of podcast
Pat what we're all like crying laughing
I love you I'm in I would do it you
gotta convince these two guys the lion
right here there's a shaman walking
around
oh my God they would love him we still
need you to bring in the living
everybody here's a question get her
together with the Psychedelic guy so
maybe they could go off for the evening
what she did yeah I think she was dating
that guy the three-point shooter I think
I don't know the way no no no no no no
no no you're positive for sure for sure
okay because he's is a very good looking
guy you know he's which guy well the the
guy that's a three-point shooter I like
him too my boy Jared yeah I think he's a
very good no he's not kidding her okay
anyway so uh uh it ended we left it was
good we had a uh the the food was good I
had a chance to meet your buddy Chris
Humphries which added a whole highlight
of the event was uh meeting your friend
Chris which was a senior connection with
him that that part was fantastic anyways
hey side note did you guys watch the
movie The Judge I haven't seen it yet
Vinnie I I swear to God did you watch
the movie The Judge Rob did you watch
you recommended it or a friend but I'm
gonna take this right now if you don't
watch it by Sunday you're not doing
podcasts
I'm telling you if you don't watch it
I'm not doing podcasts I'm watching
cancel everything I'm watching on Sunday
do you know how many people message me
you're telling me I understood what you
meant I was in tears crying watching a
judge you got to watch um I promise you
gotta check to see if Brian watched
Friday night I'm watching yeah you you
and your girl watch it together I'm
telling you you're gonna cry in front of
her okay I'll tell you why don't you do
that anyways everyone you have homework
this weekend watch the flipping judge by
the way don't use flipping in it it's
just the judge if you type and flip and
you're not gonna find it okay
um next story uh did you guys see
what can uh from Citadel said when he
was being interviewed about SPF do you
do you have that video or no do you have
that video Rob do you know which one I
think I texted it to you let me find it
very very interesting so who is this guy
are you kidding me this is the guy that
made the most money last year 16 billion
dollars he made last year what doing
what he's the CEO of Citadel okay this
is Ken Griffin Ken Griffin 16 billion
dollars last year what do you mean last
year made 16 billion that's correct
exactly what I just told you he made 16
billion last year spin it's Ken
Griffin's hand I just texted it to you I
just texted it through the video and he
moved to Miami but I want you to watch
pause it first and and you have to do it
in a way where you start from the
beginning so refresh and figure out a
way to pause and get the audio because
it's tricky when you're dealing with
Instagram okay it's fine okay you got
don't play it yet but watch this so he's
being interviewed by a uh a person who
all of a sudden gets a very very
uncomfortable when he says this that was
fine Tom have you seen this what he says
or no I have I've read about it I have
not seen it okay end to end so Tom can
you the level of credibility with Ken
Griffin is what how successful of a
guy's yeah what he does in terms of Wall
Street and the bond market and
international finance his credibility is
like an 11. okay meaning no no this is
the guy the heavy and by the way he just
moved to Florida yeah he bought a land
in Miami I like the main main place and
he's building out to his own you know
headquarters buildings there so he's a
stud I think he moved here from Illinois
Bobby watch what he says watch what he
says and more importantly watch the
reaction of the interviewer go ahead
okay that all of us are worried about
you know on the balance sheet of FTX is
a line called Trump lose
and Sam was the second biggest donor to
democratic candidates
I'm going to leave it to everybody else
to draw their own conclusions about what
you're saying here
right those are those are really really
ugly facts when you see a fraud of this
magnitude having played out and you find
no Regulators were there to prevent it
that's a really really tough story
we could talk for quite a while about
FTX sadly we don't have it yeah so I
have to finish my own
Democrats moving on right now
how uncomfortable was that silence
balance sheet um Trump lose Trump that
was a coin what was that meaning the
money they used to donate to different
places was for Trump to lose was for
Trump to lose so this fund here 29 20
you know 20 million dollars this much
money here this money is used to help
Trump lose holy [__]
that to me on this again I'll I'll play
the moderator here I don't know much
about this that to me is not that
shocking that there's people in that
space that want to see Trump lose I mean
after all what was the Lincoln project
was built to see Trump lose but the fact
that it was fraudulent money is the is
the real scam is it was just fake money
and they're donating it to the
Democratic party for Shem you know
agendas obviously we know that we want
Trump
go new May okay it was real money that
belonged to investors this was freaking
Ponzi that got redirected to Alameda the
big difference between Lincoln project
and this keep going right so what I just
want to correct what you said not
correct you personally but what you said
was this was fraud money no they didn't
invent the money this was investor money
from massive family offices and
investors that put it in there and
trusted this guy on this whole FTX
premise he moves to telemeda and then it
gets filtered out to these campaigns he
was propping up Sam SPF was propping up
SPF and then he was using FTX you know
FTX to make donations to political
campaigns and to Charities this is real
money that real people lost it's like
Bernie Madoff and um
what he's talking about
is is behind Griffin's comments is just
the depth of the fraud and what was
really going on here so it's not just a
fraud it was an election fraud it's not
just a a you know a startup CEO with a
bad moral compass this was deep deep
frauds and that was Ken Griffin's
silence while he was sitting there what
do you mean election fraud
okay so you set up a you set up an
entity in the Bahamas and then you're
making donations Beyond Federal maximums
to individual campaigns Maxine Waters
you find the video of her on the floor
of the House Representatives blowing in
kisses you're a savior come on I mean
they they knew what were the midterms
you're saying exactly let me show
another clip of this guy I mean you know
that that uh you see what's going on
look but he's not the first guy and
won't be the last guy okay but I just
want you to hear like the tone okay Rob
if you can play this clip here somebody
send this to me
I just send it to you while you're doing
this while you're doing this let's just
kind of talk about the uh uh if you if
you have it I don't know if you have it
if I texted it to you rob it hasn't come
through yet really I just texted it to
you I mean say what say what you want
bro the Democrats are gangster bro they
don't play they
they do their work bro so what do you
mean what do you mean like think about
think about now now that it's all these
years later Trump the amount of enemies
in the shadows in the face the media bro
this guy didn't have a chance like the
the I mean he won on his own Merit and
then think about all the from the Russia
collusion to this to the impeachment
they and say what you want to do the
Democrats they fall on the sword bro
they they they go down with the ship
they and look at all the look at
everything that we're finding out that
they're doing from from the Shady money
from Hillary paying for the for the
false information for and none of them
get in trouble none of them get in
trouble did you see did you see that
They removed atom shift they they
removed they remove swallow and then
they're all complaining about the fact
that this is not fair you shouldn't do
this all this other stuff and McCartney
went at them yeah they shut down all the
reporters I want you to watch this guy
and watch this guy tell me what you
think about a guy like this okay yeah
there you go people are stupid and
they're really stupid okay I mean just
being honest right so the other day I'm
sleeping my bean bag in my office and
like one of the cleaning people comes by
and she's like hey you know I hear your
big CEO you know I was like like shut
the [__] up is what I told her because
I'm like who are you I don't I don't
need you know like I'm not looking for
the help like maybe maybe I'll donate
money to you you know
and you know she kind of like took that
weird and she told me like you know I'm
a guest here and I said you know I was
like I could buy your family like 300
million times over okay and I'd still be
a billionaire most people are just not
really him is that really his voice
that's his voice oh my I thought that
was a character of like a really
annoying person but you know what you
you know you you believe that for a
person to look at everybody as I own
them I can buy you I can do this I can
do that I can do that great
uh uh but you know this is
the amount of uh fraud that's going on
within SPF and then the other day on was
it on cheddar when they call that Kevin
O'Leary and the guy says you know well
how did you go from being the person
that was anti-bitcoin you were like
Charlie Munger everything about that was
anti-bitcoin anti-bitcoin anti-bitcoin
and then all of a sudden you turn into
this guy that's you know I uh uh you
know uh fully Bitcoin and you know you
it's it's the way to go and how did that
happen that was the CNBC interview and
that was Andrew Ross Sorkin that called
them out well wait a minute you just
said 2018. have you seen this within
this whole this whole thing here with
what's going on with FTX and who's
involved look there are certain people
that took sponsorship money there is
risk when you take sponsorship money
okay there truly is risk but then
there's people
that were bought okay when you do a
little bit when you do sponsorship money
you have to find out what the product is
okay and if you have a track record of
saying yes to 100 a product that is
being sent your way guess what that
means you're not you're not endorsing
anybody You're simply taking money got
you if you get if you get 10 people that
come your way and say hey we'd like to
be your sponsor the right number is
around 70 to 80 them should be turned
down you shouldn't just take money from
everybody watch what these guys by the
way phenomenal job to both of them look
what they do to Kevin O'Leary just why
it's painful okay to brace for impact
singing the blues right now at all
oh yes I'm singing the blues why because
your 15 million didn't pan out that you
that's a lot of money this is a paid
spokesperson it's a lot of money you
didn't have to do much for that that's
pretty that's found money different
decision that's a different discussion
okay you know you can make that decision
on your own but I'm going to this point
if you want to save he's guilty before
he's tried I just don't understand it
but you went from Charlie munger's view
on bitcoin to Michael Saylor's view on
bitcoin and I actually kidded you about
it I said who are you you you you you
may know nothing but you're never in
doubt you're so strident when you said
it was just worthless and rat poison and
then six months later you're like this
Bitcoin Bull and and I so I didn't
understand that conversion did that
conversion coincide with the 15 million
that you got from from FTA do you hear
that yeah no I was investing three and a
half years earlier than that I changed
my mind back in early 2018 when I saw
the regulators and jurisdictions like
Canada Switzerland and Abu Dhabi start
to change their minds I got stop you I
gotta stop you
um you just said you made this
conversion in what year
I think it was 2018 I started investing
yeah okay well I just just for as a
point of fact for what it's worth uh May
14 2019 uh you came on television and
called Bitcoin garbage it is a useless
currency it is a useless currency that's
what I believe
by the way did you catch all of that
yeah I love it
yep put their foot to the fire good for
them so by the way shout out to Joe
Kernan and Andrew Ross Sorkin who you
know hosts the the morning Bell uh on
CNBC Squawk Box I believe is what it is
I mean look they've they have you know
how awkward it is to have someone that
maybe you consider a friend a colleague
an investor Kevin O'Leary and call him
out straight to his face good then he's
more of that you know that's credibility
right there and the reality is it's like
those are questions that you should
answer Kevin O'Leary he's like 2018 I
became a believer in Bitcoin it's like
well just
let's just check the tail of the tape
here in 2019 you called it a scam and
trash it's like garbage how does that
add up garbage I don't know not a good
look for Kevin O'Leary Mr Wonderful it's
not but you know he got 15 million bucks
for it again this is a perfect example
you can't say yes to everybody we got
these guys came up to me wanted me to do
what was a manscape right and they say
hey we'll pay this and then we'll pay
this I know I'm like dude I'm not
getting up there talking about go shave
you I'm not I'm not doing it not with
everybody that I don't care I'm not
doing it so number one I'm not doing it
but first of all that's not even a big
deal right no hey this casino site Pat
will will pay half a million dollars to
do sponsorship and drive it to our
gambling website first of all do you
realize imagine the audience I want your
kind of watches the audience watching me
say the following yeah so look if you're
like me and you bet on games use first
of all yeah but but that your Bot now if
you protect act award and by the way let
me make a very simple prediction to you
we have some people doing sponsorships
with you know who they are gold coal
Masterworks we have a few company Aura
you know udemy some of these guys were
doing Partnerships with they could still
screw up in the future but as of right
now we feel very confident about what
they're doing it's very clear we feel
confident endorsing having these
companies being used because we feel
confident about what they're doing today
there's a massive risk if you can just
be bought with a check and by the way
you just watch SPF saying I can own you
and you just watch Kevin O'Leary SPF is
right he just did two very powerful men
who runs who runs Shark Tank meaning he
is the main Talent of that show it's
it's not anybody else he's not the
riches Mark Cuban's the richest yeah and
Mark Cuban's the sharpest but Kevin
O'Leary is the one that's the most
well-rounded Entertainer [__] talker
pushes the envelope he draws people into
that show is there any legal he's the
magnifications I don't think there
should be I don't shoot it for somebody
going I'm all in even though they kind
of know I don't think he should be held
should be healthy accountable I don't
think there's any uh uh uh no no no no I
don't think there's anything you can do
to Kevin O'Leary because
realistically he didn't do anything
wrong he took money and he said this is
a company to use it's on the Judgment of
the individual that trusted him and says
this is a guy that's telling me the
individual should have said how the hell
do you go from hating Bitcoin trashing
Bitcoin I remember one time pompliano
was on the show with one of these things
and him and popular are going at it and
pompliano selling you know he's a
maximum Maximus yeah maximum he was he's
not as much as before they're going at
it they're going at it they're going out
of energy this is garbage this is this
this is that so if you watched him go
like that and then sudden flip well the
person that invested is also taking that
risk that how did you all of a sudden
think that person's gonna flip this
quickly yeah you know so anyways that
that's on the individual I don't think
it's on Kevin O'Leary At All by the way
because it's a slippery slope it's like
all right Kevin Leary he's a financier
investor he's on Shark Tank he's on a
CNBC all right he took money but then
then you got Tom Brady then you got
Steph Curry of course yeah Matt Damon
did some crypto.com so like where does
it go at the end of the day I don't
think they should be held accountable
but they're gonna their brand and their
image okay is gonna take a hit and to
sing your Praises uh number one I I use
manscape I think I keep things real
clean shout out to manscape but how many
times because at one point in 2020 I was
kind of handling some of the sponsorship
stuff here and they pitched me to pitch
you on the gambling stuff I said I don't
even want to bring this to Pat because I
already think he's gonna say no and by
the way my entire brand is save that
money invest your time don't spend your
time on useless stuff I'm like I don't
feel comfortable doing gambling stuff
and I know Pat's not gonna do but to
your credit how much stuff do you get
pitched and you're like no no no they're
willing to pay to say and say are you
kidding me we can't do it but again no
there's a lot of small YouTubers that
need the sponsorships totally get it
there's a lot of small guys that get
started that you get a sponsorship 200
bucks 400 bucks if you gamble great it's
part of your brand but make sure
whatever you're doing with sponsorship
is something that matches your brand no
matter how much people pay you but if
they pay you you take it there's the
risk that if it flips your name's on the
line real quick yeah there's a
difference between short-term and long
term short term is quick fast money
savings that you were talking about long
term is investing it's so easy to take
the short-term money yeah a lot harder
to invest in yourself and invest in your
brand for your image so it's safe to say
that because you're a man's get your
everything's clean and your things are
shiny things are looking good well good
for you congratulations I can I can hook
you up if you hook it up do I I'm gonna
Lisa how about you how about how I
broker deal you give them liver you give
a manscape deal by the way I would love
to see no no don't don't talk to a
manscape commercial you know me it's the
biz doc here keep things ready let's go
to the next story Trump and moving on
real quick
nothing to see here
Donald J Trump to be allowed back on
Facebook and Instagram so here's a
question for you
a couple months ago he first is back on
Twitter now Facebook and Instagram let
him back on which one they say Facebook
and Instagram really what they're saying
is Facebook because Facebook owns
Instagram so the last one that hasn't
said it yet is who is YouTube and I
don't even know if he's on LinkedIn or
not but YouTube is the only one that's
left to let him back on the question I
got for you is why are
the the top three most traffic websites
social media companies three out of the
five Twitter Facebook Instagram why are
they bringing them back on at a time
like this is it one they're sick and
tired of Biden and they just want this
guy to come in is it two they're afraid
that McCarthy is about to go out there
and investigate the hell out of them so
before doing that they're already
letting them lose two weeks after
McCarthy wins speak of the house oh [__]
you know what just to be nice and play
nice let's let Trump back on Facebook
and Instagram is that two or three it's
just about time for us to let him back
on it's it's business plan just like you
said with the vaccine they're putting it
in a drink right now they know you know
it's coming he's gonna now you know he
already announced he's gonna be running
for president you know much traffic is
going to be on their sites
100 he's gonna be he's gonna be on
Instagram he's gonna be on Facebook
because they're connected right Tom what
he's gonna be all over it I think what's
going on below the surface is Operation
bid bid Biden investigations DeSantis
Facebook is worried about the
investigations with McCarthy I think
you're absolutely right they want
nothing to do with a chair in on Capitol
Hill asking questions they also I
believe are fearing DeSantis the more
these polls come out although there are
some polls this week that show Trump was
doing much better
and I think it was not the
establishment's desire for
Biden to come out and say I've talked to
my wife Jill and I were absolutely
running remember that was kind of
impromptu
impromptu that was not set up that was
not a big announcement I think there are
people in the Democrat machine who are
like the DNC were like dug on it he's
not supposed to do that and I think that
they the machine wants him not to run
Tech was worried about investigations
and also they're worried about DeSantis
well what better way to help neutralize
DeSantis than to fomat Conflict at the
RNC level the easiest way to do that let
the orange man back onto
Twitter let him back onto Facebook and
let let the dust kept kick up on the
dispute I think um sometimes I by the
way I think all of you guys have some
credibility with your stories right and
and it's easy to go what you did bis I
think it's a b.i
bid I think sometimes there's these
Rabbit Hole stories we can go down a lot
of them have some truthiness to them
sometimes it's just sometimes it's in
plain sight two years ago and two weeks
to the day there was January 6th
Insurrection how this whole thing
started of of banning Donald Trump and
they put a two-year ban on Donald Trump
voila it's two years later and sometimes
it's just as easy as plain sight saying
well it's been two years we've been for
two years and it's time to put them back
on now I do think there's a lot of
credibility behind there like there's
nuanced discussions what happens if we
bring them on to Santas buy an
investigate I think all that is credible
but I think the major factor is it's
like it's reached the two-year Mark and
it's time to reconsider having them on
has he tweeted has he tweeted he has he
still hasn't tweeted no so that's just
people I love
um
how uh simple you think this is on on on
what they're doing with this letting
back on uh I think there's a lot of a
lot of strategy behind what's going on I
think Twitter was just letting back on I
don't think there was anything with
Twitter I think you know uh musk is like
sitting there saying look I'd love to
have the mega crowd back on Twitter
that's traffic that'll increase the
valuation the company I'm all in I think
to I think to musk is truly
let's get the guy back into business
right okay and he's waiting for this
right come on by the way the moment the
moment Trump tweets it'll be the most
liked tweet in the history of Twitter
the moment he tweets it's gonna happen
and they're saying he's about to by the
way oh really his Camp is saying he's
about to okay
um
Facebook and Instagram is is slightly
different on why you let him back on uh
could it be ad money because ad money's
taking a massive hit with Facebook
they're having a hard time with that and
they know if Trump runs that campaign
they're going to spend a lot of AD money
on Facebook and the one that was a
machine last time was Facebook more than
YouTube more than Twitter more than
everybody it was Facebook Facebook was
the machine that helps with elections so
they want that money and that's a lot of
money that goes to Facebook right
um you know that could be one side the
other part is you know they they may
want him to come in to make it dirtier
against the Santas because he is going
to go against the santis where it could
be a civil war where it could be them
going against each other and they like
that they want that remember when you
think about your opponent never
underestimate your opponent and how
strategic how manipulative they could be
the Demps lead the game in manipulation
and propaganda in uh creating
is going around destroying riding fires
buildings peaceful you mean pcnn
headquarters but then people are
protesting at uh you know what do you
call it uh January 6th this is an
Insurrection this is this and then the
guy on TV says I love the fact that
they're using violent with antifa just
because you're destroying property that
doesn't mean it's violent violence is
when it's towards other human beings do
you understand like they're processing
on how they're and how many people have
died with these antifa protests are
walking around with guns and riots and
how many people died with the January 6
protesting unless if you put data to
data together but what was turned into a
massive event historic the single worst
event ever worse than 9 11 was what are
you talking about right but this right
here leave them alone these people are
upset ask why they're doing this so they
they get credit for games
they get credit for that uh the one
company that we're not talking about
right now that we should notice how
Facebook allows Trump back on Instagram
and Facebook and Twitter but then Google
gets crushed this week okay I don't know
if you saw the story with Google they
get crushed cover a Wall Street Journal
main story the government is soon Google
for the second time in two and a half
years and they're going after them to
wanting them to split up okay you know
their ad Revenue a couple years ago they
were number one at 34 billion or
whatever and then they're at 21 billion
right now they're they're behind I
believe Tick Tock and Amazon or Tick
Tock and Amazon is catching up to them
but they're saying hey it's manipulation
it's gamesmanship not the right way of
doing this you're listening to what
people are doing so they want to divide
those guys up so maybe Google comes out
in the next week or two and says hey
we're letting Trump back on YouTube
because they also want Kevin McCarthy in
their Camp to take it easy on them so
all of this stuff is very uh seems very
like ah it's just day-to-day business as
usual I don't think it is on Google I'll
add one quick quick point the attorney
generals for the state of New York and
the state of California have joined the
feds in their suit
well here connect the dots on that isn't
that crazy New York and California New
York and California attorney generals
have joined the federal suit
if you want that interesting behind the
scenes somebody's upset yeah there you
go New York Times story right here U.S
accuses Google of abusing Monopoly and
Pad technology the doj and eight states
have filed an Anti-Trust lawsuit against
Google accusing it of illegally abusing
a monopoly over the technology that
powers online advertising as a first
such lawsuit against the tech giant
under President Biden and an escalation
of legal pressure on one of the world's
biggest internet companies these are the
states by the ways you're not I'm
looking at the lawsuit right now it's 15
153 Pages it's it's the US government
U.S Department of Justice Commonwealth
of Virginia state of California state of
Colorado state of Connecticut state of
Jersey state of New York State of Rhode
Island state of Tennessee jeez
outside of Tennessee those are all blue
States that's exactly I was about to say
why is Tennessee in there so Tennessee's
also getting involved the lawsuit says
Googles has quote unquote corrupted
legitimate competition there's our
favorite word competition in the ad tech
industry by engaging in systematic
campaign to seize control of the wide
swath of high-tech tools used by
Publishers advertisers and Brokers to
facilitate digital advertising
what was the number that that
constitutes a monopoly was it 60 percent
64 or 16. real quick what makes a
monopoly yeah is this 64. we're about to
find that that's not that crazy huh 64
of the market share and I think last
year didn't Google say
50.50 right
what's the number
at what percentage does it become a
monopoly
uh I don't know why by the way while
you're saying this uh the lawsuit doj
has asked the U.S District Court of
eastern district of Virginia to here it
is force Google to sell much of its
Suite of AD technology products and to
stop the company from engaging in
allegedly anti-competitive practices
well when they bought doubleclick and
they rolled it into AdSense it basically
there was certainly any Ad Agency in
America there was really only one place
to go
yeah that they had a monopoly for a
minute they don't anymore like they did
before though but they're still being
targeted so that's correct it
again a lot of these decisions are being
made right after midterms knowing that
they lost house and by the way I love
the fact that the other day Robert
Wright comes out and says so you know
the the house what are you now gonna do
about what's going on with the you know
uh guns and with unemployment and with
minimum wage I'm like dude for two years
two and a half years you had house
you had sent it and you had the White
House you didn't do [__] so what the
hell are you talking about bro what are
you talking about so again that's the
gamesmanship that is so good on what's
done on the other side you have to give
the level of manipulation that they do
you got to give them credits I always do
you can't underestimate the power of
what those guys do on that side okay uh
next story next story we got biggest pay
raises one to Black workers young people
and low-wage earners according to Wall
Street Journal uh black workers young
workers and low-income owners saw the
largest pay increases in 2022 due to
tight labor market and high inflation
median weekly earnings for all workers
were 7.4 percent High year over year at
the end of 2022 the median race for
black Americans was uh 11.3 percent and
weekly pay workers
uh between 16 to 24 years old Rose by 10
the bottom 10 of wage earners saw a pay
increase of 10 percent
these pay increases were a welcome were
a welcome relief for those groups who
have experienced Decades of pain in the
labor market however wage gains and a
broader inflation has begun to cool and
job losses are forecasted for 2023 the
rate of raises between workers 16 to 24
and other age groups widened in 2022
white and Asian workers continue to earn
more than any other racial groups okay
any any thoughts on this article Tom
uh well first of all it certainly goes
against a narrative doesn't it evil
corporations don't do anything for
anybody and while you can look back at
inflation you can look at inflation over
time and say wow it should be higher it
should be this
seems to be a positive point of progress
that's that's what I see here I see a
positive point of progress more progress
needs to be done things still have to
you know I think move forward but to say
that you know that what you're led to
believe by mainstream media is that evil
corporations are keeping wages down
they're doing this and this and this and
yet there's data points that are coming
out here that says some of the people
that most needed raises especially
during inflation actually receive raises
I mean these are double-digit percents
I look at it I look at it actually a
different way I I think this just comes
down to the the minimum wage debate I
mean what are we talking about here
these are young people low wage earners
black workers I think at least two out
of three for sure this comes down to
minimum wage this whole fight for 15
that's been transpiring for the last
five years now they're talking about
minimum wage 20 bucks certain places and
then you know minimum wage in New York
is a lot of different than Tuscaloosa
Alabama I think a lot of this is the
minimum wage debate and then
you know the minimum I think if you're a
worker and you're getting 12 bucks an
hour or 10 bucks an hour and you're
fighting for 15. I get it and you're
fighting for 15 for 20. I get it
but think about the business owner the
small business I mean you could talk
about this all day Pat
how do you make payroll sometimes you
know how do you and there's other parts
of the payroll that this is not my
wheelhouse but
um workman's comp type stuff right or
the payroll tax these types of things
that as a small business owner these are
things that you need to be considering
and that the average workers just like
[__] it I want 20 bucks an hour that's
where I got it's 40 Grand now you just
went for 10 bucks an hour all all it
does when you raise the minimum wage is
it helps the big companies it hurts the
small companies let me give you an idea
what happened with capitalism this is
why capitalism works and this is why too
much government intervention gets in the
way watch this watch what the market
does what is the minimum wage in America
today today it's like seven or eight
bucks it's 725 or some number like that
okay what where is it going to by July
do you know the number where it's going
July bucks it's going to 9.50 an hour by
July of this year okay do you know right
now what you get paid if you work at
Walmart an hour what's their minimum
wage 12 bucks an hour do you know it is
at Amazon and Target 2020 15 bucks an
hour so guess what Walmart's been having
a hard time doing
attracting people hiring people so
Walmart sat there and said dude we
cannot be given our minimum wage at 12
bucks Walmart just announced
starting wage to anybody they hire is
officially 14 bucks which by the way
it's still not 15 bucks which is Target
and Amazon so if an app if a person
wanted to go get a job and you're a 18
year old kid 17 year old kid 20 you're
like dude I just need a job that pays me
good to start off with you have to
choose between Walmart and you have to
choose between Target and Amazon where
you're going to whoever pays more yeah
the Target and Amazon pay Buck more yeah
so you know what happens who takes a hit
no no Walmart takes a hit here you're
right yeah 100 but here the point I'm
trying to make too is the following what
did the government raises the minimum
wage from 725 to 950 has nothing to do
with this yeah nothing to do with this
because they still have to pay they're
still way above whatever the minimum
wage is however
the Walmarts of the world can't afford
50 bucks an hour the Amazon and the you
know targets of the world can afford 15
bucks an hour the small little shop in
Kansas who's been there for 42 years
business was passed down from Mom and
Dad to them they can't afford to go to
15 bucks an hour right across the street
there's a Walmart opens up okay kids out
of high school whose someone's son comes
and starts working for you now that
guy's son that guy's father says listen
instead of working for Joey's little
market that he has go to Walmart right
across the street Joey only pays 11
bucks an hour such and such pays 15
bucks an hour go to them you lose You're
Gonna Take a Hit so again one side
capitals and works Market dictates wages
government getting involved doesn't work
and if you do force people to pay a
higher minimum wage the small business
owners that Purdue is 49 of all the jobs
in America take a massive hit you cannot
do that okay you cannot do that I'll
tell you one thing I've learned from you
is essentially what what the big guys
will say
to grandstand versus what actually
happened so if you're Jeff Bezos or
who's the the new CEO of Amazon Andy
Jazzy Jazzy Jeff and well all workers
deserve 15 an hour and I'm I totally
Advocate bumping that up to 16 workers
have rights let's get behind our
Workforce because they're saying that
publicly grandstanding but they know
they just took Tommy's toy store out of
business and Billy's Boutique out of
business and Patty patakes out a bit
like all these small little businesses
that you're talking about Kansas I can't
do 15 an hour I can't do 18 an hour I
can barely do 12. and so on the surface
the anti-jazzies of the world are going
to come out there in grandstand but
low-key it's because they're putting any
small competitors out of business and
that's how they develop their Monopoly
okay let's do a little math into a
little fast case study remember when New
York we goes back about seven years ago
said hey we're gonna do um you know
McDonald's and all these places and they
specifically call that fast food and
they said 15 an hour remember that
remember that whole thing okay
and you remember what showed up uh I
think it was a year and a half later
kiosks two ordering kiosks showed up and
two counter people were no longer needed
uh okay now watch this to order you're
saying order your food at the kiosk to
tap it in rather than ordering it at the
counter right yeah so there's two people
at the counter interact chaos no at a
mid-sized McDonald's Watch What Happens
the two people are now up to 15 bucks an
hour the two kiosks I pay them
electricity so now I have two people
that's 30 bucks an hour
but I have four working units divide 30
by four
seven fifty yep wow now my labor my
total labor cost to take orders is 750
an hour because I have two humans and
two kiosks what also happens is the
large part of the market solves problems
that politicians cause and if you invoke
costs The Innovation is going to come
from Innovative companies that are
trying to solve that because they're
ultimately trying to be profitable and
make a return for the shareholders and
that's a great simple little case study
on how McDonald's was forced to pay 750
an hour but the true label costs for
four counter workers was seven was
forced to be paying 15 bucks an hour for
two humans which is 30 bucks over an
hour but they have two kiosks working
divided by four it's back 750 an hour by
the way such a great case example
because we've all been to Walmart where
it's like uh self-checkout over here
yeah or you go to Walgreens or CVS it's
like now I'm the bagger no it's my job
to bag everything it's because when you
start raising the prices and they start
losing amount of employees they're going
to make you do the bagging Customer
because now there's half the employees
there and now you're incurring that cost
yeah now I gotta become a professional
Bag Boy because uh they're raising the
minimum what's wrong with being a bad
grade no you do nothing I'm sorry guys
yeah you know what I said 170 million I
know you've got to go get a job you guys
went a different route on the store
which was which was great you know what
I got from it when I read biggest pay
raises went to Black workers yeah all
were ever all we've been told for God
knows how long from the left is this is
a racist country we're systemically
racist from Pete bootage saying Bridges
and is a fact bridges are racist from
Stacey Abrams saying asking ideas for
voting is so racist that's a great
headline to see that we're not as racist
as they're saying if black people are
getting these biggest pay races and I
guess the left they might be a little
bit wrong about how racist we are with
the country
need that problem too of course you know
pin us pin us against each other that's
a big time but that's a great headline
no yeah that's amazing so okay so next
story time I know you have thoughts on
this jet base Jeff base was maybe
selling uh Washington Post to buy
commanders uh investors say this is a
New York Post story
uh that just came out so uh uh the
problem for Bezos reportedly is that the
commanders embattled owner Dan Snyder is
still sore over the story newspaper
series of exposes alleging a toxic
management culture at the team where
bosses including Snyder allegedly
enabled sex harassment some even believe
that Snyder suspects Bezos who bought
the Washington Post in 2013 for 250
million dollars encouraged the tough
coverage in 2020 and a bid to force him
to sell the team front office sports
report last Tuesday that Bank of America
hired by Snyder to auction the
commanders continues to court Bezos even
if there are indicators that Snyder
doesn't want to sell to the Amazon
founder Tom what's gonna end up
happening here well first of all
it doesn't matter what Dan Snyder thinks
Dan Snyder
uh his organization was horribly sexist
we found out what the whistleblowers
pointed out it wasn't overblown they
were not Cleat Chasers they weren't
girls looking for money this was really
a nasty environment especially the
turnover of employees and the NFL said
enough
you're selling same thing happened with
Carolina Panthers and we all know in the
NBA Phoenix owner right Pat Phoenix Suns
owner it's like hey man we need to go to
a new era you know of um of positive
encouraging
you know labor bases and workplaces and
so Bezos you know what's in the business
of selling papers so what he did he runs
stories he ran stories in the Washington
market and maybe this owner was used to
getting his way with the newspaper hey
you know the NFL we buy you know we do a
lot of things we bring a lot of money
this town you know maybe go a little
easy of us easy on us and they send
their lawyers into PR people after it
guess what gigs up and the other side of
it is if Bezos does want to buy the
commanders I don't think he has to play
this game the dense Snyder thinks he's
playing I think Bezos had called the NFL
and say were you looking for an owner
and looking to force the sale like you
forced the sale of the Dodgers when they
had a bad owner and the and the NBA in
Phoenix and all this are you looking for
someone with some dollars to enter in
this uh please hold for Bank of America
they're running the auction for us thank
you very much Mr Bezos your number is
number 622 here's your paddle the
auction starts tomorrow and I think it's
that simple the NFL would love to have
an owner like base those come in and buy
the franchise especially since Bezos is
putting his his Mansion his life base of
operations in Washington what's the
percentage that he's going to Divine it
what are the odds I I I'm at 60 and
Rising right now
because the NFL wants this to happen and
they need somebody to buy the franchise
and just like remember what happened
with Jerry down in um uh Carolina and
they're like dude you are selling this
and you have no choice you're done
and they did the Dodgers with the
McCourt family remember that baseball I
mean they forced out Donald Sterling
when they brought in you know uh uh uh
what's his name from Microsoft
great example yeah when they want to
force somebody out they know how to do
it before somebody else so if base those
minds and you think he'll change the
name to like the Washington Amazonian
something different
is a pretty bad name
and the locals logo is not logos not
good yeah the Amazonian well he he was
in battled in the whole Redskins
controversy for a decade yeah I'll just
say this about Dan Snyder number one uh
Jeff Bezos could spend 250 million bucks
even overpay 300 million what's is that
the price tag that they're asking for no
no no billion no 6 billion yeah
right now by the way he only bought the
Washington Post for 250 million is that
what that number you know what it's
worth today 251. it's uh it's gone up
that's exactly right I guess my point is
Bezos could buy that no problem here's
my thing with Dan Snyder how many NFL
owners names can you name off the top of
your head we all know Jerry Jones Jerry
Jones is okay crap you know Bob Kraft
because he's won ball seven super no no
that's NBA oh you said NFL NFL owners
Giants yeah very public family the more
I think yeah great actors uh they're out
there he's passed away exactly you know
you know you don't is okay so Raiders
Davis and Raiders very common that's not
just because I know it you know Al Davis
because he's a legacy most people don't
know who the new owner is though Mark
Davis's son okay God yeah the vast
majority of the owners that's my point
yeah is that okay why do you know those
names do you know Jerry Jones because he
was the the most expensive franchise in
the world Dallas Cowboys and it's
America's Team
Robert Kraft because he's won six Super
Bowls okay so these are Legacy Al Davis
because they won Super Bowls in the 80s
you don't know these owners names the
majority these are nameless faceless
billionaires yeah why do we know Dan
Snyder's name Redskins haven't done [__]
since the 80s yeah okay it's because his
his brand is tarnished it's toxic and
his name's always in the news because
they want him out of there what's in
what's the guy who just as selling
Phoenix Suns Robert Sarver yeah is the
new uh Donald Sterling of the NBA the
point is they're going to keep it's
almost like in politics slow drip slow
drip slow drip like what's happening
with Biden right now you might think
it's the RNC that's doing this I think
it's a lot of the DNC that's like slow
drip slow drip when you want someone out
that's it you want them out that's
what's going on with Dan Snyder is
everyone wants him out of there and
they're just gonna keep leaning on him
until he sells
okay so listen are you thinking about
thinking about going houses
yes Adam needs a paddle uh uh anyway so
Logan Paul let's talk about Logan Paul
what's going on with Logan Paul
you know your your first seeing what
happened with you know him and uh uh uh
his I think George is no longer with him
okay I think they had a fallen out
seriously yeah I think there was a fall
on that also with Mike recent Big Mike
too with Mike and uh and by the way I
think Mike is a very uh uh
very interesting guy yeah I think he's a
very very talented I think he's very
talented George comes comes across as a
very good guy sweetheart of a guy Logan
Paul comes across as a superstar super
talented guy but I wonder what he's
going through with this whole crypto Zoo
what you know the the what what he went
through with that yeah I mean but but
the company is what I'm talking about
crypto zoo and um
you know you know what I think about
situations like this sometimes sometimes
uh we hired a publicist PR fir from Once
and I went and sat down with the guys
and he says uh you know here's what you
say when it's this
and then I get him to come like okay so
that's this guy's a big shot guy we're
paying these guys twenty thousand
dollars they probably know what they're
doing and I walk with him in the car
driving home from Beverly Hills I'm like
dude I I don't even believe what this
guy's saying I could never say what this
guy's saying yeah I'm thinking to myself
so here's how we got to handle this
situation say this like dude that's not
my style to say this let's go So
eventually we're like yeah we're not
we're not hiring a publicist maybe
eventually we'll have a full-time person
here working in-house that's kind of
working with us but not going to a PR
firm because they have a simple they
have a very similar way of apology
letters like they have already 50
different formats of apologies they take
one out of nothing here's the apology
one for you to use I typed it out our
team put it together yeah they're just
pulling an apology thing that they've
used before do this do that I wonder how
much of this is Success getting to your
head I wonder how much of this is who's
in your ear I wonder how much of this is
uh being afraid because of the last time
you got canceled with Japan I wonder how
much it is is walking on eggshells I
wonder how much it is you know when Tate
says you're bot you're reading a script
a tool of the Matrix I wonder how much
of this like by the way there's there's
a lot of people that are taking a lot of
shots at this guy uh Logan I have a
suggestion I have a suggestion for Logan
Paul here's what my suggestion is I
think
it's a very hard suggestion for me to
say this it's not easy to say this and I
don't think he would do it
but I think Logan needs to take a 90-day
break and step away from everybody
say go on a 90-day hiatus hiatus from
wrestling from everything you you are a
rock star the world knows who you are
step away and go back and write down
make a list of values and principles
that you follow that you live by go and
remember the 12 year old kid you were
things your mom's taught you mistakes
you've made how you've learned from them
don't don't come back with a script that
your publicist has given you to tell the
world
speak to certain people that don't
benefit from you that don't make money
off you that wants nothing from you and
see if they can give you some direction
on how to approach this because this is
not going in the right direction the way
things are going
this there are certain times in life you
got to take 90 days off and just kind of
disappear and come back stronger I mean
maybe step away and go watch the movie
uh what is that movie Thomas not the uh
uh uh what is a Castaway no not Castaway
no the one where the guy goes away and
he gets arrested and he just reads and
recreate himself and comes back and
becomes the main guy counter monochrist
Count of Monte Cristo with the cavisil I
believe he's in it yeah to just go away
and and and figure yourself out life is
precious
life is awesome
it's horrible when you're faking it when
you're acting and you're saying stuff
that you don't believe in and uh I'm not
sure I'm by the way I believe
Jake is saying more things he believes
in than Logan is saying right now I
think Logan is being forced to say
things that he is thinking it's the
right thing to say because someone told
him to say it I think Jake just doesn't
give a [__] Jake just go out there he
goes out there and says here's what I'm
about here's what I'm doing here's what
I'm doing and I know as much as he's
more like the Maverick he's more like
the rebel what do they call him the
problem child and then Logan is the
Maverick brand that he has you know well
Jake is more straight up you know
Problem Child I think Logan needs to
take 90 days off and disappear and let
everybody says where's Logan Paul I'm
taking 90 days off and then come back up
and reappear and see what you do and
some of the relationships that you
screwed up call me with them face to
face not live
forget about the eyeballs for a second
hey let's do this how about we do this
live so everybody can see no just the
two of you there's certain things you
just gotta go away and do it yourself
and it's nobody's damn business not
everything you do is about getting
eyeballs certain things in life are more
valuable than eyeballs relationships
sincere relationships friendships things
that matter there's depth to life
uh and and I think you sometimes you can
fall for this trap of if we do this I
think this could get five million views
hey what am I we could fake controversy
to stop living that life you're too good
you have too big of an upside step away
90 days I may be wrong my suggestion go
disappear come back Shock the World with
the better version of you and then let's
see what's gonna happen to the next
upgraded version of your iOS software
that you have I like that I really
appreciate your advice because you're
not coming from a point of you're the
worst I can't believe you would do this
but you're also holding them accountable
for maybe decisions that he's sort of
recklessly made if you look at the title
of this article YouTuber Logan Paul is
taking a beating over crypto Zoo but
he's far from the only celeb hyping up
risky Investments here's why young fans
could be left holding the back here's my
question so he's far from the only celeb
we've seen what's happened with
Kevin O'Leary we just talked about that
right you took 15 million dollars from
FTX turns out that wasn't the best bet
garyvee he was doing his whole garyvee
fans all that
um Matt Damon took some obviously we saw
what happened with SPF we just talked
about taking easy money and not vetting
sponsors and what happens when you don't
vet sponsors and you're going after fads
how much of this is a crypto thing that
they just thought that they were going
to believe in how much of this is not
properly vetting who you're aligning
yourself this cannot affect the guy like
George is your lifelong friend this
cannot affect the guy like Mike Mike is
a good guy like I don't know Mike I've
never talked to Mike ever I've never had
an interaction with Logan never we've
never been to the same place so I'm not
coming from a place of having too much
Intel I'm just coming from a place of
what the world knows and what they've
been able to do with their brands the
guy I watch him wrestle I watched Logan
Paul Russell I'm not even a wrestling
guy I watch a clip of guy Sam I'm like
how the hell can you do that like
physically the stuff the guy was doing
the double flips and all I'm like that's
to be that athletic and be that funny
and be that entertaining and be like
that Charming Charisma and all this
stuff but but bro he's 27 years old Gary
knows exactly what he's doing he's in
his late 40s mentally I don't know how
old he is I think he's in his mid to
late 40s I don't know how old Kevin is
Kevin is mid 50s late 50s I don't know
Gary and Kevin know what they're doing
sketch 27 and life's going very fast
very very fast at 27. pump your brakes
take a step back talk to some real
people who have nothing to gain from you
zero people that don't even want the
world to know that he spoke to them
those types of people not the types of
people you talk to okay you want to come
on my podcast no I don't want to be on
your podcast I don't want you to be on
anything I just want to talk to you
let's see where you're at where you're
going with this I don't need any credit
for this years later if you want to talk
about it go for it he needs to figure
himself out I I just think he needs to
step away to figure himself out it can
get very ugly very quickly the way it's
going right now because you look
I I've lost people in my life okay but
sometimes in life you lose people that
you're supposed to lose because you're
growing and they're not can't do
anything about that those types of
people you lose it's totally fine okay
but sometimes you lose great people in
your life where everybody knew that
person was great for you you can't
[__] the world and say well he's an
idiot anyways no he's not he was very
good for you okay stop fooling yourself
you are the alpha the group I get you
but that girl was very good for you that
guy was very good for you that man was
very good for you I got it but don't
fool yourself you cannot lose great
people in your life who are not afraid
to tell you the truth to your face and
challenge you to improve I thought Mike
was one of those and I by the way they
may even be going through what they're
going through right now is what it is
but it's hard to find people like that
and when it all becomes like it's me
it's me it's me everybody's telling you
you're amazing they're doing this
they're doing that let me tell you
without you they would have known
anything and all this stuff people say
things like that to the main guy to kind
of get like there's very simple
languages that divide people stuff like
this you know the only reason people
know your girl is because they know you
the only reason people know your man is
because they know you okay the only
reason people know is because of your
success without you you would have never
won a champion hey look Michael Without
You Scotty would have never done this
hey Scotty without you Michael never
wouldn't people will say [__] like that
to get in between great running mates
great Partnerships you can't fall for
that [__] anyways I think he's
falling forward and I think he needs a
90-day Break by the way I love the fact
that Kanye took four six weeks off I was
just gonna good for him yeah hey the
fact that you've disappeared good for
you I think if you can go 90 days do it
okay do it but I think Logan is on the
list of right now needing to go away for
90 days
I agree and well I mean the only thing
we saw with Kanye was he got engaged or
married what happened he married
somebody from his from his Yeezy uh
thing that he he was in the news like he
said completely dropped off he's taking
his time out the only thing that you
heard is something positive by the way
the 90 days is also to leave to actually
think
and and recreate meaning you know if
let's just say we have we say hey let's
go do a business retreat for four days
we go to a house we rent in Bahamas and
for four days we get hammered that was
not a business retreat yeah you didn't
do [__] you're not coming back any
different yeah or we go to four days and
we strategize every day from eight to
five and at night we go to restaurants
we have a good time we do this and we go
to sleep at a reasonable time and then
I'm back at it again right there was an
outcome to it when you take 90 days up
it's not 90 days to go do nothing yeah
it's 90 days to go and have a personal
Intervention when you do it I've been
through before and I think it's very
very effective I've done at the right
time great things can happen to you okay
anyways that's a Logan Paul story we can
continue uh uh uh to Other Stories so
uh lgbtq families Mall leaving Florida
in Wake of new culture laws okay new
culture laws let's see what the story is
All About which by the way uh we talked
about this briefly a few months ago
Robbie price and his Husband Jordan
lechert are considering leaving their
home in Florida due to what they say is
a lack of Tolerance and policies that
marginalize the lgbtq community the
couple who have been together for 12
years and have a six-year-old son Kellen
say that the discrimination and hate
they have experience in recent years has
become in your face in Spring of 2022 a
Florida legislator enacted two laws the
individual Freedom Act more commonly
known as the stop wrongs against our
kids and employees woke Act and the
parents right in education and dubbed by
critics as a don't say gay bill that
regulates how race sexual orientation
and gender identity can be discussed in
schools
for me when I see something like I'm
gonna show you guys a video clip right
now that you're going to be blown away
by this man seriously you're going to be
blown away by this Rob I'm gonna text it
to you in a second
for me here's how this works you know
how people were saying you know uh Roe v
Wade you know abortion this abortion
that you know I don't feel safe being
gay here or I want entitlements look if
you want a lot of entitlements right now
the city of San Francisco is thinking
about giving a five million dollar
reparation to black people in their city
did you see the story or no okay yeah
did you hear about San Francisco San
Francisco wants to give five million
dollars of reparation to black people
that live in that City guess what that's
gonna do if I'm Black and I'm wanting
the five million dollars maybe I'll
consider if you can pull up that article
this is CNN San Francisco reparations
committee proposes a 5 million dollar
payment to each black resident think
about that how quickly would you want to
go be a black resident in San Francisco
that is the fastest way to attract a lot
of black residents okay if that's what
you're proposing if that's important to
you go to San Francisco if for you you
want to be part of the lgbtq community
and you want to feel free to do whatever
you want to do Florida is not the state
right now it may change it's not right
now consider going to Austin consider
going to California consider going to a
different markets by the way I lived in
Dallas Dallas had a very big a community
Tom I don't know if you remember this or
not Dallas's gay community was massive
when you would go to you know uptown not
Uptown what was it not Highland Park the
other one something park it was a
university park it was a University
Place six blocks east of the American
Arena yeah hey if you want uh abortions
right okay these following states you
know worse go to those States if you
don't want to pay high taxes you want to
pay low taxes there's five or six states
Tennessee you know Texas Florida you got
a few States you can go today can
benefit from taxes I want a lot of
entitlement and Welfare and stuff like
that go to California go to New York
your policies are going to attract the
types of people you want so I am not
surprised and I don't blame these folks
for wanting to leave a state like
Florida totally get it I suggest this
family choose a state that's going to be
a little bit more accommodating to their
policies because it's normal some places
are not welcoming of certain people I
didn't feel welcome to be in California
and a business owner I can't sit there
and [__] and whine about it I moved to
Texas and I was very happy and from
Texas I wanted lifestyle I moved to
Florida I'm very happy it could change
10 years from now based on a different
Governor it can change 20 years from now
Tom what are your thoughts when you read
a story like this my thoughts don't go
to this particular family my thoughts go
to
I get so tired of headlines that every
time someone's upset they're leaving and
going somewhere else if this election
goes the wrong way I'm moving to Canada
if this tax thing goes the wrong way I'm
moving to Canada and you'll notice that
Canada's population really hasn't gone
berserk so there's a lot of celebrities
and or people on the left that have not
gone to Canada you know so I think this
I'm mad I'm leaving stuff I think is you
know they may have real reasons behind
it but I get tired of the headline like
that it says you say
America is the greatest country in the
world and there is a there are
communities all over the place that you
may feel more comfortable in this
community and that community and you
know go find go find your comfort and I
just I just get tired of the I'm mad I'm
leaving angle Pat what you said about
find a community that Embraces you that
for what you who you are what you want
to do where you want to go or things
you're working on right now
go there
but by the way do you guys have any any
unique uh thoughts on this if not I want
to show this video to you go ahead I'll
give you one thing by the way what
percentage of people in America are gay
while it's increased it used to be less
than one percent it's at five percent
right but if you correct by the way if
there's a recent poll uh uh this is by
Gallup they asked Americans what
percentage do you think our lgbtq uh
they said 25 meaning it's not 25 it's
five percent so people get
sensationalized we had Nikki freed on
the podcast we were just talking about
this last night ironically who was
running for governor against Charlie
Chris and the Democratic party and she
was saying here on the podcast when
Jedediah and her kind of got into it she
goes you understand how many people I
talked to that aren't comfortable here
in Florida and they want to leave and
they don't like the fact that what's
going on here and DeSantis and don't say
Gabe Bill and people are moving out of
Florida and drove I said what
I go I go I don't know where you're
getting these numbers or who you're
speaking to but everything I'm seeing a
hearing feeling is people are flocking
to Florida like crazy but what you're
trying to twist right now is the fact
that people are leaving Florida because
of a don't say gay Bill and you're
bringing up this story with Robbie price
and his Husband Jordan Legend you're
making this up this isn't a real thing
you know people are coming to Florida
stop it with the nonsense nobody
believes you no then yeah go ahead yeah
but here's my thing though I I don't
know what you guys all read from that it
it's it's coming down to these two this
gay male couple who have a kid this all
comes down to me it's obsession with the
kids okay this is what it is nobody
cares if you're gay or do whatever help
you do these acts to stop the work all
both of these acts that we put in is
just please watch this video leave like
by the way you're a gay couple you have
a six-year-old kid you teach whatever
thing about gays that kid's Gonna Know
you want to leave here because why the
governor here is telling people Hey
listen kids shouldn't be sexualized they
shouldn't know about this [__] till they
get older if you want to leave because
we're trying to protect kids why what's
this obsession with kids and no we want
to teach them and leave the [__] kids
alone watch this video it's the perfect
transition into this video watch this
video good evening every teacher that
has a pride flag in their classroom
should be fired and arrested the gay
flag is a sexual flag it represents
nothing other than sexual things gay
lesbian bisexual transgender and
questioning what business is it of
anyone on this board of what children
would like to do with other children
it is none of your business it is
between them and their parents but
however you guys want to illegally
survey your students my name is Frank
Rodriguez I'm the executive director of
operations for gays against groomers I'm
a 31 year old gay man pushing back
against
that's happening within our classrooms
keeping parents away from this
discussion is absolutely severing the
relationship between a child and their
parent
my community is not discriminated
against anymore shockingly enough we
succeeded
now you're sending out surveys that's
asking students what their gender is
what their pronouns are and whether or
not you should be telling their parents
could you imagine if my son or one of
yours went to school and said hey I'm
gay and you never knew
all of you up here are pretty
intelligent
you have Doctorate Degrees you're
educated and you lead this District
but yet you turn a blind eye with the
sexual things that happen in your
classroom watch watch this I refuse to
believe that any of you think that
that's appropriate
because if you think that that is
appropriate
you would be a predator
there's images that are going to be
displayed today for you to listen of a
child
sucking another child off
and that's in your classrooms what I
shake because it makes me uncomfortable
to even utter those words to you this is
a gay man this is nothing about
inclusion it is nothing about respect to
my community
I say with you with a hundred percent
truth according to the center of Disease
Control that the reason my community
faces such issues in this world has
absolutely nothing to do with the
straight people on this planet has
everything to do with the drugs that we
digest has everything to do with our
Access to Health Care the number one
reason my community has so many mental
health issues is because they don't have
access to health care and that's the
that's directly from the CDC it is not
slurs it's not gay bashing if we don't
have access to therapy
if you really want to help the lgbtq
community to feel really accepted in
this world Embrace that people have
mental health issues and they should
seek help
having a classroom without the American
flag in it is a disgrace to this country
if this country wasn't here millions of
people around the world would perish
and that flag this flag
should be held high by every single
student dude oh my power of God holy
[__] oh do you not that was [__]
fantastic 31 year old games screaming at
the top of his lungs America First
enough with the woke agenda
that was a perfect based think tank with
Statistics and things backing up his
points like eloquent like similar saying
it right and then that Twist of like I'm
a gay guy like what the hell are you
guys doing they're sucking each other
off like he felt like he was you know
uncomfortable that was for him the same
person he's a gay guy and you can't say
you're anti-gay you're answering yeah
my boyfriend's house going back leave
the kids alone it's none of your goddamn
business yeah it's the parents
responsibility bro and if you and if a
gay couple wants to leave because the
school is not guess what you teach your
own kid whatever the hell you want leave
the ones that's going if you want to
leave bro
whether it's in social issues it's when
you're calling out your own side and say
guys enough yeah we we what do you say
specifically is like we want we we we
figured it out yeah it's done yeah now
there's this complete over correction
and this indoctrination of kids yeah and
as a gay man he's just basically saying
enough yeah enough to know and what yeah
and I questioned the other day I was
like what is the obsession why why is it
that the the powers that be want the
sexualization of kids why are they
pushing this down everybody's throat no
pun intended why why why why is it
happening palette why do you guys think
they're forcing this so much and they're
trying to make it like look at the you
know don't say gay Bill and all this of
what and why so this this just this just
makes you oh oh when you when you hear
this is the crazy thing about speakers
when I was first getting into sales I
would watch different people speak from
stage
and you know the first one was so as a
kid that I was attracted to was the guys
that just screamed the entire time yeah
and they didn't know how to like
enunciate and you know kind of go up go
down go up good job let me tell
everybody go take over the world
this is so awesome and then after like a
few months I've listened to I'm like
dude I'm burned out and then
I watched a guy would get up and speak
and then next thing you know 60 minutes
felt like two minutes
and you're like
wow I never saw marriage that way before
I never saw money that way before I
never saw leadership that way before I
never saw relationships that way before
the guy didn't raise his voice he was
just kind of talking to you and then
when he wanted to make one point maybe
we would go Elevate and you know get
excited about anything like
that was the best speech I heard
this guy didn't raise his voice stayed
at the same level for two minutes and 20
seconds or so
and I got the chills all over my body
because when somebody makes an argument
in a logical way using reasoning
and tapping into your emotions where you
don't feel like a victim you listen to
this guy saying he sounds like a person
that doesn't want you to feel sorry for
him he wants to be a leader and he's
given Solutions you just get off and you
say
great freaking Point man beautiful what
are you going to say to a guy like that
yeah okay he he he didn't do anything
but just give his argument to us and we
hurt him out okay
we need more people like this to make
their arguments a guy like this can I
don't know who this guy is I've never
met him Frank Rodriguez some of you guys
are asking about me sharing the video
I'm about to tweet it out so you can go
out there and see it and learn more
about them they're they're trying to
fight against the system that's trying
to groom kids and if that's really who
he is if this is not a spoof if this is
not a trolling if this isn't anything he
feels very sincere
people like this are going to make a
very big impact the next 5 10 15 years
what is this year that you're talking
about gaze against groomers the
Coalition of gay people who pose recent
trend of indoctrinating sexualizing
medicalizing
children under the age of uh under the
guise of lgbtq our community that once
can you zoom in a little bit more so I
can read our community that once uh
preached love and acceptance of others
has now been hijacked by radical
activists who are now pushing extreme
Concepts onto Society specifically uh
targeting children in recent years the
overwhelming majority of gay people are
against what the community has
transformed into and we do not accept
the political movement pushing their
agenda into our home gaze against
groomers directly opposes the
sexualization indoctrination of children
this includes drag queens story hours
drag shows involving children the
transitioning and what and
medicalization of minors and gender
Theory being taught in classrooms the
activists backed by schools government
walk media and corporations have been
speaking on our behalf for too long when
fighting for equality our goal was to
successfully integrate ourselves into
society but now these radicals aim to
restructure it entirely in order to
accommodate a French minority as well as
seek to indoctinate indoctrinate
children into their ideology we're
saying no wow yeah it's pretty good well
it just shows that you can't just paint
the lgbtq community with uh broad stroke
with the large paintbrush it's the
radical people what does it say at the
very beginning radical activists are
hijacking the lgbtq movement to
indoctrinate and radicalize young kids
to your point stay away from the kids
it's so refreshing to see that there's
grown-up lgbtq Community they're like no
we can be gay and we can get married and
we can fight for that like you're saying
leave the freaking kids alone yeah and I
don't understand I generally don't
what that why they want these young 6 10
12 year old kids that's my question
learning this yeah but mind you Adam
this dude like this this organization
this is the the small minority group
within that the majority of the LG they
want the kids and they want to put just
like I still question why what what is
your obsession with them bro you know
what I was slow though here's here's a
part just be patient
reasonable people will lead okay just be
patient reasonable people who present
their arguments in a way where it makes
sense the world has no choice but to sit
there and say damn this makes sense
because there's guys that are
instigators that jump in that just want
attention and want to seem like they're
for the people but they're not they're
just ass kissers like you know how they
say oh you're such a uh teachers what
was it teachers you're such a they teach
them there really is people like that of
course okay there were people that
weren't they were just helping out the
teachers and they really were the people
that were the teachers pet that were
brown-nosing yes okay there are a lot of
people that are brown-nosing different
communities to be accepted into whatever
they're getting uh
they're getting exposed and it's a
beautiful thing by the way just read
that one line it's gays against groomers
here's the point the overwhelming
majority of gay people are against what
this community has transformed into and
we do not accept the political movement
of pushing their agenda in our name
here's my question though I I haven't
seen Rob have you I have this these type
of groups are new to me all I've been
seeing all over the media is uh kids in
strip clubs uh in New York um parents
letting it's just dude it's just the
sexualization and their uh drag queen
reading while we're at school and it's
like what what what is going on bro I
don't exactly what I don't get it give
it time okay let the people with common
sense rise present your argument with
the data present your argument with
reason and and calling out hypocrisy and
majority of the people will sit there
and say this makes sense this makes
sense this makes sense you're you're in
the business of leading converting
persuading debating given arguments yet
being patient with the right people that
are reasonable to say you know what
Vinnie I kind of see your point that
that's what that's what we're doing
anyways let me share this one story
about the top Russian official warns of
global tragedy if allies send Ukraine
new weapons this story is on January
22nd it's page seven if you want to go
to it the story's on page seven and it's
interesting what just happened yesterday
so a leading official in Russia
Parliament has warned of a global
tragedy if Ukraine gets new weapons from
allies as the bitter fight between the
two Nations near the 11 month Mark uh
volodian speaker of State Duma Russia's
lower House of the country's Parliament
issued the ominous message Sunday he
said supplies of offensive weapons to
Kiev issue a regime would lead to a
global catastrophe a global catastrophe
only means the n-word nuclear right he
claimed the United States and NATO's
assistance to Ukraine has led to a
terrible War 4 voladen is a closer Ally
of Vladimir Putin he also is a member of
Putin's Security Council he said if
Washington and NATO Supply weapons that
would be used for striking peaceful
cities and making attempt to seize our
territory as they threatened to do it
would trigger retaliation with more
powerful weapons so what does U.S do
yesterday how many tanks did we give to
Ukraine yesterday I think we gave him 31
tanks if I'm not mistaken 31 Abram tanks
if I'm not mistaken was given to them
yesterday I think the number is 31. can
you zoom in a little bit you're correct
there you go the U.S will send 31
powerful battle tanks to Ukraine joining
Germany and sending the vehicles to
support the fight against Russia's
Invasion the decision to deliver the M1
Abram
Abrams Tanks was announced just hours
after Germany said he would send 14 of
its leopard two tanks to the battlefield
Berlin also cleared the way for the
European countries to send german-made
tanks from their own stocks Ukraine has
lobbied Western allies to send military
equipment for months there you go so
yeah here's the other part let me just
say this anytime I want to get your
thoughts on this Russia
this is more to Russia than anything
else
you you this this whole thing if they do
this it's going to be catastrophic if
they do this it's going to be
catastrophic Russia's been saying this
now seven times six or seven times and
they've done nothing okay catastrophic
you know what they're saying to you
Russia No One Believes you anymore they
don't think you're gonna do [__] they
don't think you can do nothing now thank
God some people who are listening to
this Russia doesn't listen to this
podcast Putin's not sitting there saying
let me see what they're going to be
saying on the pbd podcast okay because
if he did hear this on the podcast he
says oh yeah oh yeah boom right
retaliate but the truth of the matter is
you can't threaten somebody six or seven
times and not follow through and the
other side says yeah whatever here's 31
more tanks yeah whatever here's this Tom
what are your thoughts well I think the
sooner that this thing gets resolved uh
the sooner the West can start picking up
the trillion dollar tab it's going to
take to rebuild Ukraine because it's the
breadbasket of Europe it's a huge
manufacturing base and there's a huge
rebuild that's necessary but I'm agree
with you this feels like the mother that
says one more your kids having a tantrum
on the floor and Target one more time
Jeremy no ice cream one more time Jeremy
no jelly beans and then it's like hey
I'll give you a gum if you'll stop right
so I I think I'm I'm kind of kind of
over it just like you are because I just
think that I could do something or just
stop saying it that's exactly right and
I think what the West remember the West
was reluctant a year ago to send Stinger
missiles little stuff yeah now we're
sending 31 of the most advanced battle
tank which will more than meet up
against those leopard two tanks so
um Germany's leopard two tanks and the
Abrams together are going to over match
uh the Russian side and I think what you
have here is I think the West is
possibly coming to this point of you
know the sacramentalism doesn't work
writing big checks and doing all this
incrementalism doesn't work let's just
send the big stuff in there and let's
get this thing over with because
remember when Russia was brought to its
knees what 30 years ago 35 years ago in
Afghanistan if you've ever seen the
movie Charlie Wilson's War you know what
I'm talking about they have eventually
turned tail and go home and you just it
takes overwhelming force and I don't
think they're going to do anything and I
think it's a very real question is is is
Vladimir really healthy right I think
that's a very real question that's a
different question the question here is
11 months you're not making progress
you're not coming across as the winner
you're not imposing yourself they're not
intimidated you're turning their leader
into a hero he's looking he's being
promoted as the next Churchill being
bullied by a guy like you you're being
compared to a guy that used to live in
Germany who took his own life some say
uh you know you're not this is not a
good storyline for them okay your people
are leaving your country you were the
number two country in the world for
immigrants Russia was number two believe
it or not for a number but they're 11
million number one is us at 41 million
Russia's number two you can pull up the
data if you want to pull it up top
countries in the world in Immigration
you've been losing immigrants that are
leaving your place this is not a good
look for you okay
uh this is not a good look for you and
it's hurting you so what are you gonna
do now zoom in okay used to be Russian
house Germany okay so Germany's two
Saudis three Russia's four that's not
even close the US is running loud to
everyone just so you know that number
two years ago in 2019 Russia was for
because we were at 41 million now
they're four okay there you go you're
declining on the list of immigrants
wanting to go to I wonder why and they
thought that and I know we got to wrap
up yeah they thought that winter you
know Winter's coming with the gas and
oil and everything that you know that
Russia
um gives to the world as what they um
export would break the backs of Europe
but Europe is still doubling down
Germany's still sending tanks the EU 100
is behind uh Ukraine it's it's
backfiring like crazy and coming down to
the bite Administration bro like this is
this this is how to be in a war without
saying you're in a war okay like that
proxy wars whatever ever it is if I send
if I want Pat you all three of you to go
do a drive-by and shoot up uh Rob's
house and I Supply you the car the guns
the ammo and you guys go and shoot up a
bunch of people and kill a bunch of
people guess what legally was gonna
happen me as the sender of all this [__]
you're the you orchestrated it you
started you're supplying all this [__]
you are just as much as in trouble as
they are so we are at like you said
we're not pasta we're involved bro we're
so involved but they'll never say the
bite Administration will never be like
yo we're in a war trust me bro we're in
it they're only a few years ago the
Winter Olympics were in Sochi yeah and
we were talking about a new Russia and a
new era remember all that and remember
that was the Winter Olympics when it
didn't snow which was really
inconvenient for the Winter Olympics but
uh you remember that there was no snow
but at that time remember oh it's a new
Russia the Cold War is Over they're the
host of an Olympic games all these
things going on and now and now look
where they are I mean this is this is
pretty pathetic anyways so folks
um it's the end of the podcast a lot of
you guys DM me or tweet and ask me
questions about what's going on with the
live podcast we're about to launch it
this week meaning physically live at the
new office with the Cigar Lounge being
done all of that stuff with the crew
home team talking issues we're probably
gonna do a three or four hour one for
those of you that haven't yet signed on
to the text list
the moment we send the text it's gonna
sell out within 30 minutes a few
thousand people have already registered
for the text community that want to be
one the first if you want to be known
told the moment we announce tickets for
sale for the first live podcast meaning
live physically live with us at our
valuetainment building
text award podcast to
310-340-1132 once again
310-340-1132 the ward podcast text it to
310-340-1132 the moment we have the site
set up to sell the tickets I think the
event's scheduled to be in February
we're gonna send a text to that group
and like this within 30 minutes tickets
are gonna sell out so text award podcast
once again
310-340-1132 let's put the phone number
below as well in the chat so people know
as well have a great day podcast